歡迎回來 趙華
我們今天的大來賓很久沒有來了
因為我們換了一個攝影棚
他說從我們換棚之後沒有看過我們
好 今天來的人
我非常非常的尊敬他
因為在外資圈他是一個傳奇人物
那他現在也在做自己的對沖基金
那每一次呢
幸好今天我們請到他
因為他每一次的電腦展
都會帶來滿滿的收穫跟觀察
我先來歡迎他出場
這個騰旭投資的投資長
也是Jonah建長陳振華
哈囉
鄭華好 各位觀眾朋友大家好
那我們這邊先介紹一下
跟我們的官員朋友介紹一下
建長陳振華
其實是蠻久的朋友了
見證了一些
建長很厲害的事蹟
其實在當年外資圈是很難進去的
看過有很多是那種
國外長春團名校回來的
都不一定能擠進外資圈
可是建長是台大畢業
其實是沒有出國留學的
可是卻從元大被挖到美林
這在當時是令人非常震撼的一件事情
算還可以啦
就是在interview的過程中
當然英文絕對不會是我的優勢
因為我又不是老外對不對
又沒有在國外留學
那當然可能跟
當時跟我的老闆在interview
比如說就是像Sophia Chen 陳舒芬
或是Dan Heller 何浩銘
那可能會標榜的就是說
那我可能在業界的人脈
或者是產業的知識
可能會稍微強一點點
類似這個樣子
大概用這種方法去包裝
那當然會找一些證據去講說
為什麼這方面會比較強啊
然後有機會就是表現得好一點等等的
大概是這樣的一個背景
你最近這幾天看了電腦展
你覺得從展裡面會覺得這一波的AI趨勢
能夠繼續點火無線上鋼嗎
應該說AI的趨勢點火無線上鋼
跟這個展當然有關係
但其實台灣的廠商展的是比較偏硬體的東西
那但是目前AI說實在
它市場會一直往上去
大家覺得沒有泡沫
還是要看軟體有沒有賺錢
那最近目前來講
其實在Computex之前比較震撼的
就是Entropic賺錢
然後Entropic今年
我們只有講去年年初的AR是一個Billion
然後到五六月可能就跳到四個Billion
年底接近十
最近就直接跳到四十幾個Billion
那目前他們年底
對今年年底的預估
本來預估就要做到一百個
一百二十左右
就1200億
現在看起來又直接上鏽到
可能會到1500億
就150個Billion
所以成長的速度非常快
然後甚至會變成
他竟然第二季就提前賺錢了
也就是說這個新創
他已經錨起來燒錢
很用力的燒錢 努力的做RD
雇了一堆人
結果發現我賺錢速度還比較快
居然還燒不夠
居然還已經BRAVEN開始賺錢
所以這其實是一個
蠻振奮市場的消息
也就是說CSP應該會持續的
做更多大量的一個資本支出
所以這個反而是
其實跟台灣的展覽
比較是偏新技術的部分
但是實際應用的部分
讓市場很振奮
就是說確定AI不是泡沫這一點
那反而是看到這些
真正的做AI的軟體廠商都開始賺錢
消費者現在願意付更多的錢
去買更好的服務
以及更穩定的一個模型
那這些模型廠商可以賺錢
就會投更多的東西
所以他已經成功的用免費的策略
然後把大家騙上車
那現在就開始要你付更多錢
那剛講的是企業端
以消費端來講大概就是
Google或是OpenAI之前告訴你
一個月二十塊吃到飽
然後你就已經可以有不錯的服務
最近有在玩的應該都會發現
變笨了 變慢了
他現在開始鼓勵你升級到兩百塊
要不然的話你的服務等級就變差了
這一次看展我覺得最比較特別的地方
其實在講光通訊
就是現在市場常常講CPU
現在看起來CPU的來臨應該越來越快
Maveo當然有講說什麼資料中心全光互聯等等的
的確Maveo也有一些CPU的產品在會場
有一些地方有在Demo
簡單來講這一次我們再看
Computest其實Demo
不管是VR200的這個REC
或是GP200
那這些REC的架構都跟之前長得差不多
所以大家看來看去可能覺得跟兩年前是一樣的東西
但只是裡面的晶片變得更強勁
那當然比較不一樣的就開始很多人會告訴你說
我的光通訊越來越重要
所以像我們舉例好了像那個圍影的攤位
他就有Demo一個他跟IRLAB合作的一個CPU的產品
那基本上你做去圍影的攤位
那個位置大概是人最多的地方
一堆人就集中在那個地方
就在跟IRLAB在Demo他們的產品等等
那另外的話像比如說MediaTech
MediaTek
那連發科他們也在這次的會場
Demo他們的CPU的Solution
然後告訴你他們
這個也會做PIC跟EIC的
這些細光產品
然後做到這個CPU的一些
光纖的一個傳輸
那其他地方有些公司
有一些Private Boots
就是私下的一些
比較沒有開放給大家看的一些房間裡面
也有Demo他們實際在測的一些CPU的產品
所以這一次讓我比較
壓抑就是CPU的時代應該真的快來了
因為至少你已經在展場都看到產品
那我們一般來說就是
如果是你在比如說美國的展覽
像OFC、OCP
在那邊看到可能是概念
概念的東西
然後量產可能要好幾年
那以前我們看Computation很特別
Computation的Demo通常是準備量產
就是出現在這邊的東西
大概就是半年到一年
或最多一年半大概就會量產
所以現在看起來CPU的時代就快要來了
那當然這邊剛剛有提到
順便講到這個Intel老闆來了
其實以前他是主角
其實以前Intel是主角
以前的Computax就是Intel加Microsoft
當然現在主角是乾爹嘛
就沒問題全民乾爹
不過Intel因為最近一個月的股價很犀利
所以大家也會注意它在吸引玻璃機板的進度
對不對 先進風暴的進度
對應該說大家比較欠Intel
第一個是CPU缺貨啦
所以其實不管是這一次Gensen的這個GTC的主要的演講
它花了很大的篇幅在講未來CPU的使用
包括在就是所謂代理型的Agentic AI這一塊
那可能CPU的用量會大幅增加
NVIDIA當然想要搶佔這個市場
他們希望能夠搶佔的理由就是
Intel當然產能可能比較緊一點
Intel現在狀況就是它的SERVER CPU大部分都自己做
它的消費性的CPU當然有奧售一些給台積電
但SERVER端目前大部分是自己的產品
所以它自己的產能有限的狀況下
它CPU這麼缺
所以它的生意當然很好也漲價
但是就有一些空缺給競爭者可能有些機會
所以像Jensen就會特別提出我們的Vera也不錯
可以搶佔一些Share
所以大概是電腦展的另外一個主軸
我覺得這一次很多就在強調CPU
過去兩年都在講GPU
但這一次NVIDIA也好
這個Intel也好
或是很多現場你可以看到
NVIDIA這個Vera的一個CPU Rack
那這也算是會場的另外一個重點
好我記得剛剛去年講了
為什麼說AI泡沫
就是擔心大廠的投資沒有辦法回收
可是現在看起來
大家回收的狀況都比預期好
消費者願意掏錢之外
消費者可能在股票市場也有賺到錢
好然後再來剛剛提到的
CPU的攤位
不是講到那些像什麼上全
PoroA
講到的是像微影
聯發科甚至大力光
這類型是很賺錢的公司在發展
所以這個錢
在AI市場裡面的正循環
現在看來是一個非常好的狀態
是的 沒錯
因為大家都賺到錢了
所以比如說大家都會說
台股到底漲了這麼多
會不會很貴
其實這就是一個
是Yes or No的問題就是說你如果看過去的因為很多人都會用過去的本益比来看用2025年赚多少钱你就会发现贵的要死但我们资本市长现在很多都是用2027年赚多少钱来看
甚至有些人如果成长性展望比较明确一点的
都看到2028了
所以你用长期一点角度来看
很多人会觉得其实现在不贵
因为你用更后面的
获利数字真的抵律的时候
那的确它的评价可能就不是那么贵
所以像我们看到Intel来
会想到可能是跟台移电的竞争
可是事實上大家各自在自己的領域上面
都是賺保
然後產能很緊的一個狀態
現在的狀況有點像是AI市場太好
所以每個人都魚露均沾
所以以前我們在
比如說AI之前好了
每一年市場我們可能要判斷
各種各樣的一些故事
有些故事是真的
有些故事是假的
那真的故事可能就不多
一年就那麼一兩個
那常常會被假的騙到
然後就馬上就把它賣掉之類的
但今年你會發現就
十個故事可能有八個都是真的
是
對 然後真的有那麼一兩個假的
其實莫名其妙長不起來
你發現假的在賣可能都來得及
那反而是變成說故事太多
但是我們的體力不足
我們的研究
研究的這個頻寬有限
我們可能十個故事
我們只有花時間研究兩三個
所以對我們來講就是
到處大家都在爆牌
大家現在應該發現很多人都在爆牌
而且可能爆的牌都是真的
而且是準的
對 是準的
講著就噴
對 那對我們來講就是
我比較喜歡就是說
我掌握度高的我就包著
掌握度不高的
也許參與一下 也許不參與
大概是這種感覺
那我覺得其實今年對股市來講相對是
我想目前大家應該同意啦 是好做的
就是你只要 不管你是看哪一個租權
只要你這邊掌握度高
其實最後都有表現 大概是這樣子
不管是追夢
或者覺得它的本益比現在相對合理
都可以
那外資報告其實我看到大部分都出到
2027是至少了
對 2028的也有了
已經到這樣的程度
不過這一次在這個電腦展前
回答的演講裡面
很重要的一件事是
公布了一個叫做
RTX Spark的一個晶片
說真的這可能要建長來講
因為建長研究半導體非常的多
我們自己有延伸啦
例如說它帶動了很多資訊軟體啦
它帶動了很多的變革啦
到底這樣一個晶片
它能夠導致台灣整個供應鏈
到底是誰受惠最多
說實在就是一個PC CPU而已啦
所以也不用把他照顧
那等於是一樣就是因為
Intel的CPU在缺貨
那特別是Intel的產能都會拿去做
企業端的東西
就是Enterprise這邊的東西
所以對於消費性的產品
除非台積電產能有提供的
不然它可能就會放掉
它會寧願放掉
就是說我把產能專心拿去做
企業端SERVER這邊的東西
那所以當然對
剛講的就是
其實現在的市場是你有產能
你就可以有機會去賣一些東西
所以像輝達因為跟台積電的N3
當然也簽了蠻大的量的一個合約
所以其實這一陣子
大家有講說什麼Rubin 延遲
延遲半個月 一個月 兩個月之類的
那我們在上游也有看到類似的狀況
但是對他來講就是
我可能稍微有點延遲
我把這些訂單往後推出要兩個月
但中間空下產能他要拿來做CPU
因為CPU是缺貨的嘛
所以像大家會討論幾家公司
比如說聯發科
大家會覺得說
你有很多產能是做這個手機
那現在手機不好
你就可以把產能拿來給Google做TPU
那CoreCon
其實CoreCon最近在漲也是一樣的意思
就是說
你有很多N3產能做Smartphone
Smartphone很差
那你就可以把這些產能拿來做CPU
還聽起來挺剛好的
對 而且更貴
對 而且重點就是
因為台積電產能都被Fully Book
所以這些人事先有Book產能的人
反而是有辦法去搶到一些產能來做CPU
大概是這樣的一個狀況
所以聯發科剛剛提到這RTX這個產品
Spark其實它就是一個PC的CPU
那其實這不是聯發科賣
這個是NVIDIA要賣
聯發是幫它做裡面的CPU帶
那搭配NVIDIA的GPU
然後去賣這個市場
那當然它的標榜的市場比較像是
有點像現在的Mac Studio
就像Apple的Mac
Apple的Mac Studio拿來做AI其實很好用
因為它有很大的記憶體
它就有什麼96G或者是
甚至有到更高的記憶體的一個比例
那目前NVIDIA就這個
剛講的RT它Spark就可以做到128GB的記憶體在裡面
所以對於一般的企業
如果我要跑一個AI模型來說的話
就是電腦跑一些AI模型
那它的記憶體容量其實是蠻夠的
那你可以去使用
那當然它其實還會比較偏
這種企業跑AI模型用
因為對消費者來說它非常貴
因為現在重點在那 128GB的記憶體
那 128GB記憶體至少2500塊美金
所以你再加上你的CPU
你這台電腦一定是十幾萬
所以消費又不是拿來打電競的
好 但是黃雲鑫有認為
他這樣做是有機會讓每個人
擁有自己個人的超級電腦嗎
就是你個人的電腦來跑AI
十幾萬你OK嗎
如果你個人真的覺得這個東西
有給你很大的產值幫助的話是可以
但它就是一台十幾萬的電腦
簡單來講
但是它可以跑AI的確是這樣子
電腦會不會擔心像記憶體的價格這麼高
它就會成為一個反轉的稻草
就是因為剛剛講消費性
我們等了好幾年都復甦不了
是因為記憶體越來越貴
可是它這樣子的價格影響消費市場
它不會變成一個逆的循環嗎
它應該說現在的狀況是變成說
在買記憶體的最大的買家是這些CSP
這些企業這些CSP
那他們的預算目前我們看起來
就是在增加
所以他明年還會買更多
有錢最大
對 所以我們上一直都講
去年這個六大CSP
就是Google Meta這些公司
他們大概去年花了四千五百億美金
今年他們資本就是七千億
現在因為剛剛講的
他的客人也賺錢
所以他一定要投更多錢
所以明年一定是投一兆或1.2兆
所以他的預算出來
他就會買更多記憶體
我們這假設記憶體
那我們這些要買
內容 notebook 什麼設備的都
所以這些所謂的記憶廠商
他光是賣記憶體廠商
賣這些CSP好了
他的獲利明年就會比今年更高
因為這些人有更多的預算
所以對他來講
他根本就不在乎
其他的這些消費者到底是怎樣
因為這些人就把產能消耗掉一大半
所以我覺得現在的問題就在於
記憶體你很難預期他繼續漲價
因為真的太貴
你連CSP都覺得貴
你如果記得今年每一家CSP出來說
我資本蜘蛛上修
就是因為記憶體太貴
所以連他們都覺得記憶體非常高
現在記憶體占到一般
基本上伺服器可能也是三四十%的
占AI Server 可能也是20%以上的Bone
所以它的比例真的非常高
所以要漲不容易
但是對記憶體廠商
有像一個很不錯的狀況就是
我這個價格也許不能漲
但是我可以維持好一陣子
這大概是我們過去幾十年研究記憶體來
沒有出現過的事情
記憶體飆漲之後
最後一定不漲就是跌
你很少看到記憶體會漲上來
然後開始止穩不動了
所以最近很多人在看記憶體市場
在想的事情是它的評價方式會不會改變
因為以前我們都用所謂的PB
就是股價淨值比來看
因為我們都覺得PE不準
因為這個E是波動的
我今年賺錢明年就賠錢
後年搞不好就虧錢
那就賺一年賠三年
類似這個樣子
但現在如果我這個獲利
真的是可以穩定的維持三年
那市場是不是開始要用
一個穩定的角度來看
那可能是用PE來看
而不是用PE
這也是美光這樣子調上去的原因對 因為其實我們之前在講就是怎麼說像比如最近在講漲別的一些零件不管什麼吸金源被動元件都是在漲的時候最美麗
然後在漲的時候
大家顧不出
你的獲利的上限是多少
所以它就可以
有一大段波動的一個行情
記憶體最近比較沒有
因為它漲不上去
所以你的獲利都算得出來
反正產能是固定的
那增加多少也知道
價格漲不太上去
所以獲利都算得出來
所以它沒有那麼美麗
但是忽然發現說
如果它變得穩定
那這件事情
就跟以前不一樣
那我就可以從PB
變成PE的一個角度來看
所以最近的確有可能
會有這樣的一個轉折
所以AI cycle
把整個記憶體的
這個景氣循環的這個
過去的這個Pattern改變了
變成一個不怎麼循環的行業
那也是一個非常了不起的
一個現象 對
因為這個現象
確實市場上也在討論
記憶體是不是不再是景氣循環股
藉由這次AI的發展
很有機會看到這樣子
與過去幾十年
不一樣的一個盛況
只要這些人繼續願意花錢
花的錢還越來越多
那記憶體就有這麼多的買家
那你就很難預期記憶體會疊加
會變成這個樣子
至少它的會比較穩定一點
大概是這樣子
記憶體的盛況沒看過
發哥快到五千塊
我們也沒看過
所以剛剛從MVD的晶片
回到看到發哥的本身
因為今年我們都知道
如果以今年發哥來說
雖然還有講
他的Exec的營收會翻倍
可是他畢竟是很小的
因為手機市場的衰退還是比較嚴重
但在明年後年
我看到應該是高盛吧
把後年的EPS估到好像400塊錢還多少
這是有可能發生的嗎
要分這樣子講
因為現在簡單來說就是
發哥去年的營業額大概6000多億台幣
就大概200億美金左右
那所以20個Billion
所以他說今年的AI
他們原本說做一個Billion
現在變兩個Billion
就算是兩個Billion就10%
所以其實沒什麼貢獻
而且今年手機還衰退
所以他去年的EPS是70塊左右
今年大家都估計一定是衰退
所以他今年是一個衰退的狀況
但是明年現在大家顧AI的市場
就不會是只有兩個Billion了
現在市場一般來講
如果像Consensus預估
可能都到10個Billion
或甚至到15個Billion以上
那最主要就是它現在這個TPU的狀況
看起來開發的還不錯
而且AI的單價的確很高
我們這樣舉例好了
為什麼可以直接顧明年到十幾個Billion
因為Blockon就是目前做Google的生意
它現在一年的生意就是幾十個Billion
它今年大概做Google的生意
市場預估大概就是30個B點
300億美金
所以就已經9000多億
那明年大家都會認為
Google的生意會重複
每個人都認為反正就像NVIDIA
業績每年大幅成長一樣
Google的TPU今年比去年成長一倍
明年可能要比今年成長一倍
所以這個市場如果今年是30個B點
大家認為明年可能就是50到60個B點
那這裡面你去假設一個
發哥的市佔率好了
10%就是6B
假設30%就快20B
所以它明年
為什麼大家會估到10到20個Billion這個數字
因為其實很簡單
就是這樣算而已
沒有什麼很高深的技巧
這個假設你可以說合理
你說算不算樂觀
有點樂觀
但是有沒有合理還算合理
那後年為什麼會估得更高
因為理論上剛剛講
Google如果明年是60個Billion的
這個TotalTPU的生意
到後年可能就會變成100個Billion
那100個Billion到時候發個
如果一樣是30%的市佔率
那就是30B
比它去年還高
比它去年全年營收還要多50%
這是一個蠻驚人的一個成長的數字
那當然如果不止30%呢
因為最近像一些報告都在講說到
後年2028年V9的這個世代
那的確有看到
Blockhart目前好像並沒有在裡面
那所以代表發哥的市占率
搞不好不止原本大家市場預估了30%
所以照這個狀況來看
Gomen預估這個400塊的數字
是不是一定不會發生
是不是太樂觀就不好說了
就跟剛講
Depend on 你預估Google的生意有多少
以及發哥的試占率有多少
那你要算出這個數字來是有機會的
好 因為為什麼會問建長這個問題
因為半導體業界也會吵
說發哥有可能到後年有30%試占率嗎
他們技術有跟上嗎
或者是他們人都被NVIDIA挖走了
但是建長以對發哥的了解來說
你覺得有機會
因為目前剛講的的確
這其實也不是我講的
Same Analyse都有寫報告
他們就直接寫一個報告說
V9沒有看到Blockon
只看到連發哥
那所以當然這個假設是變成發個百分之百
有沒有那麼誇張我們先不講
那百分之百就有點非常
好的有點讓人不可自信了
但是百分之
就是如果真的沒有伯康的設計
做個百分之五十以上
好像並不是沒有機會
是 好因為講到剛剛外資的預估
這邊的話最近外資的目標價
每一個都是一個比一個誇張
但是我覺得最厲害的是
誇張歸誇張都還到價了
例如發個一千多塊
看五千塊他就到五千塊了
所以投資人該怎麼來評估
因為我們在錄影前
其實Jonah 建長你跟我們聊過
現在大家產能都滿了
所以要看誰真的有漲價的能力
才有辦法把價格再乘上去
不然產能滿的話
營收會變成固定
那這邊的話有台電 聯發科
國劇委創 鴻海 信華 南亞科
大家都給很高的目標價
像我們的股王
大摩已經給到23456
給他第二個順子
一開始是12345
這些我們到底該如何評估
你覺得可能性
一般社目標價就是
最常見的方法就是
就是2500就設3000
3000就設4000
4000就設5000
這麼簡單的嗎
5000就設6000
對 這就是
因為除非你想當歸它
如果你沒有想要當歸它
你就是一直維持Buy的話
那你就是跟著去調
那當然
它會設定一大堆的理由
就告訴你說你要怎麼調
那你用PE
你就要想辦法把EPS估計上去
那你用PB的話
不管PE或PE
你就是要把EPS估計上去
然後去調這個目標
或者是
你現在2026年算不出來
2027年也調不過
我用2028年來算好了
不管怎麼樣你要找一個理由
那你去設這個目標價
那只要你不想當歸
你就會馬圖馬圖
絕大多數的目標價
說實在都是馬圖馬圖算出來的
所以我們對於這個目標價就
說實在的也不是那麼的care
因為簡單來講
多頭也不用預設高點
那重點是這些股票
為什麼會一路到價
然後一路往上走
因為最主要還是
AI的這個需求持續上漲
我覺得我要回到最最主要的地方就是
這些AI公司是不是開始賺錢
然後賺得更多錢
然後賺得比你想像的還要快
那所以導致CSP
願意花更多錢
花的比原本想像的還要多
然後繼續加碼做投資
那然後這樣的狀況下
當然對供應鏈的公司
他們每一個的獲利的想像
可能都會變大
那剛剛就提到一個問題
CSP願意花更多錢
但他們不見得買得到
足夠的東西
那因為現在很多東西產能都有限
那當然最明顯的就是這樣
大家都知道台積電COWAS就有限
COWAS就是一個BOTLNAKE
除此之外
其實PCB版現在也是一個BOTLNAKE
光通訊的雷射也是一個BOTLNAKE
最近甚至講說
其實NLCC沒有那麼缺
但是高容量的NLCC是缺的
低容量消費性用的當然不缺
但高容量是缺的
所以其實很多東西
你要看它的上升現在有一點變成說是卡在某些環節你不一定看得到量有比想像中來的更高所以今年的股市會比較喜歡買漲價概念股因為就是量衝不上去
所以當我們講你的EPS要算得出來
或算出來有漲價才會漲
那漲價的概念股就會有EPS的漲價
所以大家今年比較喜歡玩一些漲價的東西
或是有機會缺貨的東西
我們一般講長短料
那缺貨的時候長料是比較危險的
短料的話就代表說
最後一個才會砍到它
真的聽到市場有什麼風吹草動
可能先去砍一些藏料的單
那最後才
那時候你再開始先修正你的部位
可能都還來得及
所以大家會去找一些短料的部位
然後做一些投資大概是這樣子
因為剛剛也有問街長說
為什麼最近是台積電漲得比較慢
對不對 因為台積電看來就是
非常缺 產得非常緊
但不會漲價
可是因為它今年其實不會真的漲價
因為年初只會調一次
對 它就是每年固定
跟可能調一次價格
然後一月份新的價格出來
一整年就這個價格
那除非你說這個台積電要改變
他們以前跟客人的交易
是 有可能嗎
假設不會
但這個年頭什麼事情都有可能發生
我只能說根據我們的了解
應該不會啦
但老闆會不會忽然改變形意也不好說
因為我在想說台積電現在在這些公司裡面
當然你說什麼維生洪凱
他們評價也是算相對合理
他評價也不高
一直就是一個25倍本益比
為什麼不能直接把它調升到30倍 35倍呢
不能調到30倍
我說市場現在
因為你看它的目標價
其實大部分都3000塊錢
可是它最近就是一個還漲的格局
沒有辦法像聯發科這樣子
一口氣往上衝
像國劇他們給的保守
它卻一直衝
應該說一樣就是說
簡單來說
台積電就是一個
你獲利都算出來的公司
對 那算得出來就很透明
沒有神秘面紗了對不對
對 然後你是因為
其實另外跟台積電一樣
便宜的是NVIDIA
就是一樣你其實都算得出來
然後獲利都不錯
但是說實來大家會喜歡玩供應鏈裡面
比較高級的股票
因為資金只有一套
現在市場並不是說資金非常非常的氾濫
其實大家都知道缺錢
比如說大家最近在講說不限用途
現在都是滿的
融資都是滿的
所以要借錢其實越來越難
沒有那麼容易
你錢就只有一套
那動能交易來講
你就會跑去找最有動能的租群
那前一陣子是光
最近可能是被動
下一陣子是什麼不知道
台積電就很難被動能交易調上
它可能就只有
我們一般來說它大概就漲某一段時間
簡單來講
它通常最後一漲的時間就法說前一個月
所以比如說
下一次是7月法說
6月中到7月中
這是它最容易漲的時段
因為6月中到7月中就會有一堆消息
什麼它又要上修全年的財務預測
它又要上修CAPEX
它又要上修什麼有的沒有的東西
最後可能都沒有發生
然後再公布完之後再慢下來
有可能
但這段時間就會有很多這樣的聲音跑出來
因為它就是一記給一次彩測
中間也不會去修正
所以它只有在法說前一個月才會漲
所以每一次法說完之後
通常法說後的第一個月是比較沒有表現的
第二個月是盤整的
第三個月才會再往下走
所以你要說為什麼沒反應
因為你現在是在沒反應的那兩個月
沒反應的那兩個月
從六月中到七月中
它可能就會表現不錯
好 這就是我們媒體最喜歡的地方
因為等到六月中之後
他就會開始猜測
才一定會不會調高資本支出啊
然後明年啊
跟客戶搞不好會突破慣例的漲價
對啊
最後可能宣布沒漲價
然後很失望又跌回來
但是這會中間就有這種
想像跟炒作的空間
是 那剛剛舰長也有提到
先漲了 例如說
像上半年光其實是先漲的
後來光休息了
繼續漲被動原件
然後半導體設備其實也有漲
那當然大家都會圍繞在
所謂的五層蛋糕論
不過我們想要聽聽看舰長的想法了
大家現在一直輪動
最近是又輪回到老AI的身上
那下半年您覺得像這次看展
你有講到CPU跟光這兩項
那有沒有其他今天我們還沒有聊到的
簡單來講就是
目前看起來整個AI硬體裡面
就是剛剛提到的
隨著你的GPU架構演進
那你產品規格會增加最多
然後最值得期待的大概有幾個
那光是其中一個我們剛剛提了
那另外的話我覺得比較值得期的
一直都是類似高速傳輸的板材
那所以像CCO的升級
這個一直都在持續發生
從N7到N8到N9
那這個也是過去一陣子以來
一直表現都不錯的一個族群
那它也一樣
它也是供應鏈目前最缺的一個環節
因為不是PCB本身缺 是CCL缺
那CCL為什麼缺
因為最上有的波纖也缺
那波纖缺是因為上面的玻璃砂也沒擴產
所以一整掛其實是類似一個聯動在一起的狀況
所以這是一個就剛講
也是一個很缺的一個行業
而且產自力在增加
那另外一個我覺得
其實Computers也有到剛剛來不及講
就是電
那電的部分特別是接下來我們現在
這個從VR200到明年的Rubin Ultra
其實開始就會往HVDC去做轉換
VeraRubin其實已經是HVDC ready
但大部分的廠商還沒有對應
但是到Rubin Ultra 因為你貴的Power consumption
可能就超過5-600KW以上
所以用HVDC就是高壓直流電
這個比例就會增加
那當然對於Power來講
我們一般換算回來
就是PerGPU它用的瓦數會增加
PerWAR它用到的這些Power IC的Content
就是它相關的這些PSU等等
它的使用量也會增加
所以Nane加起來
它隨著GPU成長
它會是一個很明顯
超越市場成長的一個族群
所以在電的這個部分
也是一個蠻值得看的
另外剛剛講CPU
CPU其實現在是缺貨
CPU缺貨大家就會去看說
CPU的供應鏈裡面
又是什麼東西比較缺
所以類似比如說它的關鍵材料
當然像ABF也是一個比較緊的狀況
當然就一樣反映到
就是日本的Bitem 台灣Unimicron等等
這些相關的公司可能都是
都是會收回到這個CPU缺貨
類似這樣的一個情形
好 今天很謝謝建長來
也等於是我們下半年
還是圍繞在漲價缺貨
這個從去年漲到今年的
只是大家會有點輪動
而且我覺得因為越缺
所以本來可能像
漲到兩三千塊錢的太光電
它就可以漲到五六千塊錢
就變成大家在評價上面
是有點無限一直往上墊高的
好 這樣一直墊高
到底有沒有任何我們要注意的風險
最後給觀眾一點點提醒
我覺得其實目前來講
最關注的一定是
總金方面的話一定有一些問題
總金面的話當然就是有
這些貨幣的流動性的問題
所以比如說你的十年利率
忽然增加到4.5%
那會不會油價上來
繼續影響通膨
這些總金的變數本來就三不五十會影響
但是這個變數只要比如說
伊朗戰爭不要惡化
不要又打起來
然後礦日費時油價永遠下不來
通膨一直飆
年底變成要升息
那當然這就是一個整個
像2022年的一個大修正可能會發生
那收發市場沒有預期會發生這個事情
但是如果真的往這方向走
我可能要注意
那總經方面的話
以產業來講
我們關心的就是AI的市場
到底會不會忽然成長死樓盪
比如說我們剛剛講Entropic
現在大家已經預估它從
目前44個Billion的ARR
就年化營收到年底要衝到150Billion
會不會忽然過了兩三個月
發現衝不上去
要下來